good morning believe nation today's
message is be the here of your own movie
over to you Joe Rogan be the hero of
your own movie if your life was a movie
and it started now forget about whatever
financial disasters you've had personal
failures relationship failures
what would the hero of your life's movie
do right now do that do those things we
define ourselves far too often by our
past failures we look at our past and we
say well that's me that's not you you
are this person right now you're the
person who's learned from those failures
and you can choose to be the hero of
your own movie right now write down your
goals write down things you want to
improve write down things you won't
tolerate from yourself write down things
you've done in the past you never want
to see yourself do again and go forth
from here as the hero of your own movie
build momentum build confidence and
momentum with each good decision that
you make from here on out you can do it
anyone
do we live in unique times we live in
one of the rarest times in human history
where you can choose almost all the
input that comes your way whether it's
the movies that you watch the books you
read the podcasts you listen to you can
choose to be inspired do that do that
and be the hero of your own
so what'd you think what I love about
this is actually taking action for your
own life so being the hero you're the
one writing the narrative of your own
life not letting the past define you so
for me for example I had a rough past
and I let that define me for the longest
time I was the girl who was not
comfortable with her body then I became
the girl that was too comfortable with
her body but not really all of that was
defined by the judgment from others now
that I'm in my 30s I'm gonna take the
action to actually write the narrative
to my own story I am strong I am funny
I am inspiring all of that so taking
action of your own life versus letting
the past define you or letting others
define you is not the way to go that's
what I discovered so I love I love this
message because you take action for
yourself I think people are just too
afraid to be the hero I think it's just
it's so much safer to be an extra in
somebody else's movie than to be the
hero in your own movie and we just
constantly look into other people for
happiness or blame other people for our
unhappiness right you're unhappy it's
your boss's fault is your clients fault
it's the president's fault the
government's fault your cities well
there's always somebody else's fault and
if that's your narrative then you're
never going to go off and do great
things where if you accept
responsibility and say like I'm here
because I mean it doesn't matter who the
president is it doesn't matter what city
I'm in it doesn't matter what background
I came from who my parents are or how
much money I have I'm gonna go make my
life amazing I think people can
conceptually understand it I think it's
just it's hard to do it takes courage
and it takes the willingness to go out
and do something that maybe you've never
done before and so having those goals
and having something that really is
meaningful to you and then surrounding
yourself with things that motivate you
and inspire you to want to be that best
version of yourself I think is important
so they can go out and write your movie
instead of being an extra and somebody
else's so what I actually really love
about what evan said is that not
allowing whoever your politician is or
your circumstances who your parents are
to define what you can do when you take
responsibility and take accountability
of who you are
guess what you are the person that could
make things change you're the one who
could take action when you are
responsible for your own life so I love
that's great so the question of the day
today is what's holding you back and
being the hero of your own movie I like
it leave it in the comments below we're
gonna join in the discussion so thank
you guys so much for watching I hope you
have an amazing day we believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is and we'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso